Okay, here's my version. First thing we do is, we
call our make_salt function. We imported hashlib so we can
have SHA256. And so, first I create the hash, this
part of the response. SHA256 of name plus pw plus salt.
Call hexdigest on that. And then I, we return that,
and the salt separated with a comma. So let's give
this a whirl. We run this function and we see
we get this nice hash and we get our salt and
if I were to run this again, I should get a completely different hash and a
completely different salt. There we go. And I
can keep running this and keep getting different answers.
So you can see the salt basically adds an extra
bit of randomness to, to what we're going to see in our
hash. And it prevents a, a would be attacker from
pre-computing all of the possible hashes. And it also prevent a
would be attacker from you know, of course seeing all
of our plain text passwords. So now we've got a reasonably
decent password hashing thing. There's a, we need to write
one last function in this. Let's go ahead and do that.